[Music]
hello to the student andrés gonzález and these are
the most relevant news of the day
a resident of las vegas faces
charges for threats against the
governor steve if only that in
social networks according to court documents he
is faithful he wrote at least 34 times in
the governor's facebook page
according to county prosecutors
the defendant on the spot to violence with
his comments while
defense attorneys allege that his client
only used his right to free speech
the state tourism authority
announced that the fireworks and the
Gathering large crowds on the
Las Vegas strip as in years past
will be replaced by
virtual celebrations this New Year's Eve this includes
the midnight countdown and
exploding a 2020 number sign
to usher in the new year if you wish
more information about this event we have
a link on our website
news now dotcom
changing the subject the latest report from
the builders of the new
albicans stadium indicated that the work was completed
with 25 million less than the budgeted cost
sanz is looking for the total amount of the project
was 2 billion dollars,
including taxes, land and construction costs,
continuing with sports
a professional team of scourges  could
be on its way to southern nevada
in an exclusive interview with
the team owner lets the golden knights
bill folk and revealed that he is trying to
bring in a professional lacrosse team
by 2022 according to fail and the new
team would use the facilities of
the silver nights
henderson minor league hockey team for their
games and to plan for the weekend
let's see what the temperatures have in store for us
in the extended forecast today we will have
a high of 66 degrees and a low of
36 with cloudy skies so be aware
be very careful with your pets and your
plants on Saturday and Sunday in the
high 50s with partly clear skies.
cloudy entities and all the information
for today many listeners gonzález and
this was about the news
now in Spanish
[Music]